de son côté Laurent cell a commencé son
trek
il y a un mélange de toutes sortes
d'orchidées de Fougères qui aiment se
coller sur les vieilles branches comme
ça
il y a trois sortes d'orchidées au Laos
qui poussent dans la terre les
Terrestres celles qui sont collées aux
arbres et celles qui se sont collées au
rocher la première orchidée qui a été
identifiée c'était un Bulbophyllum comme
ça avec un bulbe donc en vieux grec ça
veut dire testicule
après une petite heure de marche
Isabelle et Antoine vont pouvoir
observer quelques unes des orchidées les
plus rares au monde
avec son ami guide
des plantes médicinales pour lui cette
forêt est une pharmacie géante
les racines de ces plantes tu peux t'en
servir si tu le fais piquer par un
serpent ou pas un scorpion
ça donne un goût sucré dans la bouche
c'est pour le diabète non
il faut tout manger
pour prendre le jus
et comme la nature fait bien les choses
la pharmacie sert aussi de garde-manger
quand ils ont pas de citron ils
utilisent ces fourmis pour les manger
[Musique]
il les écrase ça fait un goût acide et
ça remplace au citron avec les autres
c'est fourmis ils font des très bonnes
soupes
c'est bon pour la santé
c'est ce petit écran
voilà
qui servira de cadre au déjeuner
alors ils mettent tout dans la feuille
de banane
l'omelette et le barbecue génial
[Musique]
et Antoine
je suis ravie que ce soit exactement ça
c'est à dire quelque chose de très
authentique de sauvage dans son jus avec
des guides locaux adorables du village
et puis avec Laurence qui est quand même
mettre en la matière donc c'est fabuleux
c'est une très belle expérience
[Rires]